Just two and a half seconds of distraction can become dangerous on the road.
One Silicon Valley company says it has the solution - a way to be an extra eye for driver,...
...by using cameras, sensors, image recognition software, and real-time alerts.
Distracted.
So we'll alert the driver that he or she is distracted.
Then, the driver's able to look up,...
...maybe notice that traffic has stopped in front of them,...
...slam on the brakes and avoid that very common rear end crash.
Nauto's device sits behind a vehicle's rearview mirror...
...and comes with cameras and other sensors.
So you can see here there's an interior camera that faces the driver,...
...and then an exterior camera that faces the road ahead...
...and we're running algorithms to detect high-risk behaviors.
That behavior could be falling asleep behind the wheel...
...tailgating or checking a cell phone.
It will show a series of progressive alerts based on how distracted they are.